hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
here is what some complete absolute
abject lunatic said while i'm off
let's be clear tim scott does not
represent any constituency other than
the small number of sleepy slow-witted
sufferers of stockholm syndrome who get
elevated to prominence for repeating a
false narrative about this country that
makes conservative white people feel
comfortable that's an oxymoron a black
republican it is so surprising
particularly coming from ben carson who
quite frankly what happened in the
african-americans
and elsewhere did he bang his head he
drank the kool-aid that's what
republicans want from their negroes he
does not seem to understand
and a lot of them don't seem to
understand
the difference between um
a racist country
and a systemic
ra and systemic racism and then tim
promptly returned to the sensory
deprivation egg he calls home clarence
thomas is now very very much out of
control did any of you guys trust uncle
clarence oh clarence thomas
i went to law school with him
he's been
a person of grievance for as long as
i've known him if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're for me or
trump then you ain't black